toujours la désolation à bhopal au
centre de l'inde où les techniciens
tentent aujourd'hui encore de
neutraliser les émanations de pesticides
qui ont provoqué la mort de plus de 2500
personnes
un bilan qui s'alourdit de jour en jour
hier par exemple 110 nouveaux cadavres
ont été découverts dans des cimetières
musulmans
selon les spécialistes il reste encore
aujourd'hui 30 tonnes de gaz dans les
réservoirs de lusine de yunyang carbide
sur le terrain la population demeure
très démuni malgré l'envoi de secours
et ce matin mère teresa prix nobel de la
paix est arrivé à bhopal pour rencontrer
les victimes du gaz
mère teresa qui sait ce qu'est la misère
veut dire le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
jérôme bunny et bruno carette venu
spécialement de calcutta mère teresa est
arrivé ce matin à bhopal s'est
immédiatement rendu dans une école de
jeunes filles
la venue de mère teresa à bhopal c'est
d'abord l'arrivée d'une missionnaires de
la chrétienté dans une ville qui se
partage entre musulmans et hindous
mais à bhopal comme à calcutta ce qui
compte avant tout pour elle c'est d'être
présente aux côtés de ceux qui souffrent
il faut se souvenir aussi que les
enfants les adolescents étaient les
victimes les plus nombreuses du gaz
mortel dans l'école que nous avons vu
par exemple dispensant des élèves ne
sont plus revenus depuis le lundi 3
décembre
ou bien le sont au nombre des victimes
ou bien l'os plus revenir dans la ville
maudite
il était 10h ensuite ce matin quand mère
teresa s'est rendu à l'hôpital central
de la ville où les victimes continuent
d'affluer chaque jour
soc le mal que je sais venu donner mes
mains pour aider les victimes et donné
mon coeur pour les aimer nous faisons ce
genre de travail depuis des années des
soeurs sont venues avec moi de calcutta
pour aider les secours
les médecins quant à eux ne connaissent
pas les antidotes aux intoxications et
ils se contentent le plus souvent de
thérapeutique d'urgence
bien ceresa est donc venu apporter un
message de paix dans une ville qui reste
sous le choc ce qui s'est passé le 3
décembre dernier
et ce ne sera pas chose facile pour elle
que de calmer les esprits de la
population alors que jour après jour
qu'il est de plus en plus évident que
l'accident aurait pu être évité un
rapport présenté par les experts
américains devant le parlement indien
dès 1982 faisait état de toute une liste
de lacunes du système de sécurité
aucune suite n'a été donnée à ce rapport
d'autre part le registre de services de
lusine atteste il ya eu une première
fuite
la veille de la catastrophe exactement
80 ans et il semble que les responsables
de l'union carbide et fait passer des
consignes de discrétion avant la
sécurité des habitants